want to preview wildcard weekend on the
afc side man i'm walking i'm in
cincinnati right now i haven't seen this
many bangle shirts and stripes in my
lifetime vegas coming off that overtime
win into cincy how do you see this one
playing out
well i'm not going to give you too much
information but i think the the thing
that i'm watching is how quickly can the
raiders turn around and and bring that
same energy they went into overtime they
expelled a lot of energy very exciting
game a lot of times
it's hard to come back and play with
that same level of energy so that's what
i'm watching it can they come back and
match that energy
after an overtime game and the way that
one was and i always think it's a lot
harder flying to the east coast because
you lose all those time you lose all
those hours man i took i took the red
eye last night this eye you know my
right eye is pretty straight my left eye
just a little crooked you know and so
vegas is gonna have to deal with all
that how about the new england patriots
and the buffalo bills those two they
know each other so well man first
thought
for me i'm focused on matt jones and mac
jones and he talked about he was
embarrassed man don't be embarrassed to
get better you got to do a better job
man now it's the playoffs you're no
longer a rookie and you know the buffalo
bills are going to show you different
looks so mac you got to step up if if we
want to win
i can't wait to watch that game we're
going to learn something about we're
going to learn something about mac
that's how i feel about it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports